hi there Steve Kaufman here and today
I'm going to talk about a subject that
has come up before and that is fluency
in three months I'm going to talk about
this for a variety of reasons but the
basically the trigger why I'm talking
about it now is because my friend Benny
the Irish polyglot has announced his
most recent project which is to achieve
a b2 level in Japanese in three months
he's going to do this in Valencia Spain
where he's studying Japanese in
anticipation of going there after three
months I don't remember how long he's
going to spend in Japan when he goes
there
so I watched the video I'm gonna leave a
link to the video then he is very
anxious to have you watched the video
and subscribe to his channel so I'm
helping him achieve a little bit more
you know notoriety fame whatever which
I'm happy to do because Benny is a great
motivator and if you watch this maybe it
video you will come away I think as I
did with the feeling that here's a man
who is encouraging people to learn
languages who doesn't he's not afraid to
show his own mistakes or shortcomings he
has a lot of enthusiasm and he's showing
people a way to learn a language so that
the message fundamentally is positive
however when it comes to the actual
substance of the message in other words
that you can achieve B 2 which is
fluency in 3 months in a language like
Japanese which is very different from
any language that Benny knows um do I
think that is possible
No do I think is realistic no and I will
explain why and I even think that while
it Benny carries it off because he's so
enthusiastic in this video but overall
as a message to language learners I
don't think it's a very constructive one
now I want to first of all tell you what
b2 in the car
in European framework of reference or
frame of reference whatever it's called
b2 corresponds to it is can understand
the main ideas of complex texts on both
concrete and abstract topics including
technical discussions in his or her
field of specialization can interact
with the degree of fluency and
spontaneity that makes regular
interaction with native speakers quite
possible without strain for either party
without strain for either party can
produce clear detailed text on a wide
range of subjects and explain a
viewpoint on a topical issue giving the
advantages and disadvantages of various
options is this achievable in 3 months
sitting in Valencia studying Japanese no
in fact Benny more-or-less admits this
in his video and he sort of says failure
is an option in other words he is
encouraging himself to learn he set this
unachievable goal and he's shooting for
the stars and he's going to work very
hard that part of it is very good I have
no doubt that he will work very hard and
I have no doubt that he will learn a lot
of Japanese and that he will arrive in
Japan with you know a great advantage
and probably further along than many
foreigners who have lived in Japan for
many many years for all these things I
salute him a great thing to be doing but
the message that you can achieve this
level of fluency what I just described
in three months it to me to me is almost
a distortion of language learning
what's the hurry what's the hurry in
fact to achieve that level of fluency
you have to have a lot of experience
with the language with the people with
the culture you have to understand
context there's a lot of things that you
simply cannot achieve no matter how hard
you work you know in a period of 3
months I think the language learning
process itself is enjoyable and I think
one of the things that we need to do is
to find ways of learning languages that
are enjoyable as Alex
our Gaia's said in a video which I'm
going to talk about in another video of
mine where he talks about polyglot Ori
he says that that is a number of very
interesting things that language
learning is fundamentally an
autodidactic process of interaction with
the language you yourself have to
interact with the language teachers can
encourage can provide feedback but
ultimately the successful language
learner is reacting in a self-motivated
way with the language that's how he
learns he also our genious also points
out that many polyglots such as alex
such as myself such as Benny all have
techniques on how to do this
autodidactic process and while there
will be many points in common there will
also be points or techniques or methods
that are different and this is going to
depend on what we like to do
circumstances time available and so
forth and we'll see this here with Benny
Benny's focuses on speaking he's always
said to speak from day one and here he
says he going to be speaking from day
one however many hours a day one or two
with his Japanese tutor and he will also
be studying he shows he got some books
in the background and he'll be working
with flashcards but the motivation for
him is to do all of this stuff so that
he can then speak a little more the next
day which is fine I would take a
different approach I would focus more on
listening and reading initially building
up my vocabulary and my ability to
understand to a point where actually I
can have a more meaningful discussion
with a tutor but you know the key thing
in language learning is a self-directed
autodidactic process of interaction with
the language you're obviously going to
want to do the things that you like to
do and the things that work for you I am
sure that I mean I see some of the
methods for example that Luka uses he
translates from the language he's
learning
into his own language and then back into
the target language again I'm sure
that's an excellent at a very effective
way of learning we also have Alex who is
our gayest who is very fond of shadowing
which means reading text out loud while
walking and which I'm sure and many
people claim this is very effective I
won't do either because I don't want to
I'm not writing a test I learn languages
for enjoyment I enjoy the process I have
for the last week or two been refreshing
my Italian and I'm having a ball I'm
listening to podcasts about you know
Charlamagne
Carla mano van GOG very interesting
podcast in Italian almost the word so I
don't need the text now I'm going to
start focusing again on Czech so I'll go
back to very interesting text that I
have with audio and I just like doing
that so and as long as I'm interacting
with the language I'm learning if I were
in Benny's shoes he's saying for example
he's not gonna read he's not interested
in reading he doesn't like reading my
approach would be to focus on building
up my comprehension therefore I would
want to read because reading is a very
good way of acquiring vocabulary and
learning about the country and the
culture in the history and so hot zone I
will build up I would have as my goal if
I were going to Japan in three months I
would build up my comprehension skills
for most because once I get to Japan
I'll have I think a lot more opportunity
to speak so I might have as was the case
with Romanian I might have you know
three hours a week or so of Skype
discussion not for the first month but
starting the second and third month but
mostly I want to build up my ability to
understand so when I get to Japan is in
the case of Benny I will stumble for the
first week or so but then I'll have lots
of chance to speak and if I understand
what people are saying and I've yet if I
can read things around me and if I can
read the newspaper and so
I'm going to be doing a lot better so
but that's you know I think the
important thing in language learning
what I kind of want to focus on here is
I think language learning is an
enjoyable activity for its own sake and
we should learn to do it in ways that we
find enjoyable so if it's enjoyable
what's the hurry
second of all I will pick up on
something that Alex our genious said in
his video and that is that he feels that
the sort of emphasis on quantifying in
language learning is not helpful in
other words how many languages do you
speak he says it's not a meaningful
question because he speaks them all at
different degrees of fluency and some of
them may lie dormant for a while he
can't just turn them on so he doesn't
like answering that question and he also
thinks that the emphasis on proficiency
tests testing our levels b2 b1 whatever
he thinks that's not so useful either
what he feels is useful is finding
efficient ways of learning and I would
add enjoyable ways of learning and
learning in ways that enable us to
maintain our languages I think this is
also another important point if you
learn a language for three months and
leave it it's very easy to lose it and
so you I feel it's important to have
ways of learning that you find enjoyable
so that you can always go back to them
and refresh and maintain and even
improve your languages and I know that
for example in Czech now which I've been
away from more or less for eight months
I go back and I grab a beginner book and
very quickly it all comes back to me and
I can almost hear again the recordings
that are used to listen to in my earlier
content and I'll do that for a couple of
days interspersed with the more
difficult stuff that I'm I'm doing it
and the whole process is enjoyable but
my check hasn't gone away it's kind of
subsided a bit but it can be very
quickly brought back because I learned
it through a process of a massive input
and exposure in a very enjoyable way so
it's not a chore it's not unpleasant I'm
not
in a hurry I'm enjoying it so following
up on that then rather than worrying
about how much we can cram into three
months how quickly we can learn how many
languages we speak all of this
quantifying I agree with Alex we should
focus on quality how efficiently how
enjoyably can we learn to what extent
can we learn languages in a way that we
don't lose them that we retain them and
can maintain them and I think those are
the important things and that kind of
activity is a life long endeavor we
never totally master a language we
shouldn't forget them either and we
gradually accumulate more and more
languages and I think they're I think
Benny has with his Japanese but you'll
follow up with a visit to Japan he'll
have there a base such as he has with
Chinese and that he can build on over
time in order to take those languages to
the level that he is at in his Romance
languages or in German it's going to
take a long time it's not going to be
three months and so to that extent I
think the the the idea that he
encourages people with his video and to
judge by the comments on his YouTube
channel people are encouraged and they
appreciate his energy and his honesty in
you know exposing his level in the
language so it is a positive message
message from that sense but for the many
many people who find that they you know
three months goes by very very quickly
if you start a new language especially a
very different language like Japanese
three months goes by very very quickly
and to even suggest that you could be at
a b2 level after three months is it in
real terms maybe not in terms of Benny's
objectives which is to stimulate
interest in language learning but from a
realistic point of view it's not
achievable so I don't want to start a
controversy but I just think it is
important to make the point for me to
state my beliefs and my beliefs
therefore
our that language learning is immensely
rewarding not only because of what we
were able to achieve ie potentially
fluency in the language but the actual
process itself it's a process of
discovery it's an enjoyable one the
brain learns but it learns slowly I look
forward to your comments thank you for
now bye